now now my love my brother fought valiantly
for you now she did my queen here is your
tent Lord Baelish good night do you want to
be a queen no I want to be the queen [Music]
and those tales have taken root deep inside
of me pardon me stop my lady you'll ruin
your dress I have others whenever you look at
this night I want you to remember your father
the imagine you might be rather cold the
climate is a bit more forgiving back in
Highgarden your grace shall I have them bring
you a shawl Lily I am touched by your concern
your grace luckily for us Tyrells our blood
runs quite warm doesn't it Loras yes Fathead
father grandmother sons are think of us you
might think we have some wits about us one
of us at any rate his father was an oaf as
well my husband the late Lord Luthor are you
sure lady Margaery doesn't find all this bit
macabre and I was quite all right your grace
I'd love to see their tombs really it's like
taking a walk through history open the doors
Joffre wait [Applause]
so I prayed that she'd catch a horrible
skin disease a week after that she came
down with porridge plague porridge plate
but you don't have it in the North your
skin starts to look like boiled oats and
eventually your face slides off and you die
in agony that's awful you're I believed
you and if you were to marry Loras Oh
your place would be at Highgarden wouldn't
it my son with him I'll have to we'll have
to he's rather good-looking even
with the scar especially winter
this girl we're going to be sisters
soon you're a musical girl aren't you
one who brings me the best necklace will
get to keep the next best one day my lady
I will avenge our King Joffrey is our
King now I meant no offense and you've
given my love come back to me it's time for
my father's toast the evening before Luthor
was to propose to my sister I got lost on
my way back from my embroidery lesson and
happened upon his chamber how absentminded of
me hmm but if my mother can be our secret if
we're going to be man and wife we'll
have a few secrets from her I hope I
[Applause]
won't even know what to call you sister
Oh mother hmm what's your name Oliver
my lady I'm afraid my brother is
keeping the King waiting Oliver
has ever anything I can do for you they
were very sweet Tommen seems quite taken
with his you cream I absolutely adore
him you raised a gallant young man I'm
forever grateful good a wife sells
her husband's wounds a mother sings
her son to sleep you learn quickly
seven blessings to you grandmother
[Music]
shall we pray